j'ai dépensé ma jeunesse comme une
poignée de monnaie j'ai fait un peu le
tout un peu partout sans savoir et après
la fleur aux dents c'était tout ce que
j'avais bien je savais
toutes les femmes ces mots de m'accorder
il ya un incident entre rêve et c'est là
qu'ils ont
il y aller quand regrettes et celles qui
laissent de remords il ya le fait que
leur
mais celle qu'on
reese jours
j'ai connu à lille et en rien du tout
coloré
défaits 3 / 2 1 2
ces dégâts j'ai connu bien des gens je
les ai tous bien aimé
mais aujourd'hui
de plongée
rien fait l'a cherché hilale évident
c'est là mais qui l'ont mort il ya les
pics on regrette décèle jollès des
romains il la fit prix que l'on aime et
c'est ce qu'ils ont
mais jouer
non non
un jour ici l'autre là un jeu riche et
l'autre à pain j'avais peur de devoir de
tout savoir
j'avais tellement d'affaires à me
tromper de chemin
gk manoubi n'est pas en trouver celui
qui mena doit il aller ridoret
c'est là qu'il en bas il ya des regrets
more heroes
il
et c'est quand on avait trouvé la femme
qu'on aimait en 1936 qu'on en faisait à
peu près on l'a mené au casino au bord
de la mer avec un beau clair de lune et
on lui faisait danser le cha cha cha